nichts ist so beständig wie der wandel
an denen gewöhnen wir uns der
nachrichtenredaktion irgendwie auch
immer aber auch nicht so richtig wir
müssen uns ständig anpassen aber nicht
nur was wir berichten
ändert sich die ganze zeit sondern
natürlich auch wo wir das tun bzw in
welchen formaten wer das tun
das heißt wir müssen die ganze zeit
gucken dass wir up to date bleiben
wir beobachten aber auch dass unsere
arbeit dabei nicht nur gelobt wird
sondern auch natürlich kritik abbekommt
vor allem wenn dieser wandel für einige
leute nicht schnell genug geht weil die
sich etwas sehr mehr zügigkeit wünschen
aber auch bei anderen wenn sie denken
wir entwickeln uns gerade eine richtung
die gefällt mir nicht wir wollen
deswegen von euch heute wissen was wir
besser machen können noch besser machen
können viele sind ja zufrieden aber da
ist immer noch luft nach oben
deswegen sind wir dankbar wenn ihr eure
kommentare anregungen wünsche hier unten
rein schreibt und auch ganz generell
vielleicht fragen an sonst habt über
unsere arbeit wie wir arbeiten was wir
den ganzen tag über hier erleben
diese antworten die wir dann einsammeln
kommen alle direkt von meiner chefin
bettina schausten der stellvertretende
zdf-chefredakteur in und leiterin der
hauptredaktion aktuelles wie das bei uns
heißt da sind alle aktualitäten darunter
heute schon mal heute die verschiedenen
heute sendungen die heute plus auch und
ich freue mich dass sie heute da sind ja
ich freue mich
danke für die einladung vielleicht noch
zu ihnen erst mal was ist denn in den
letzten jahren für sie die größte
umstellung gewesen wenn sie überlegen
was so die nachrichtenberichterstattung
angeht ja ich glaube das liegt auf der
hand das war natürlich der umstieg im
grunde aufs netz das internet das eben
den journalistischen beruf ja auch total
verändert hat ich hab noch studiert ohne
internet und
hab dann immerhin meine magisterarbeit
schon an einem computer geschrieben war
damit relativ weit vorn es ist
tatsächlich so ich will jetzt keine
alten geschichten mir erzählen
aber das ist ja so ein grund stürzender
wandel gewesen der jetzt ziemlich in
mein arbeitsleben gefallen ist und das
kann man heute gar nicht mehr
vergleichen
wann haben sie das so gemerkt das erste
mal dass sie sagten okay krass da ist
was im wandel das lässt sich nicht mehr
aufhalten
also ich war lange auch reporterinnen
dann redakteurin und die handys haben
erst mal finde ich viel verändert das
war so mann war plötzlich ständig
erreichbar wenn man früher als reporter
unterwegs war tauchte man ja mal sechs
bis acht stunden ab und machte seine
geschichten und war unterwegs und die
redaktion vertraute darauf dass man
irgendwann auch wieder kam ich habe
geschichten gehört das land kein geld
dabei hatte dann wird man schnell per
fernsprecher apparat irgendwo eine
fußgängerzone zu hause anrufen konnte
auch das allerdings gar das brauche ich
zum glück nicht
vielleicht ist das auch nochmals zurück
aber nein das war tatsächlich so und
dann hat sich total verändert und früher
haben wir dann noch die agentur zettel
gerissen und irgendwann kam dann halt
der umstieg und der umstieg war ja nicht
reibungslos sondern wir sind da auch
viele technische hürden ja mitgegangen
und auch viele dinge die überhaupt nie
funktioniert haben und dass irgendwann
war ich froh als als sich alles mal ein
bisschen sortiert hatte so bevor wir
jetzt in die diskussion und in eure
fragen und kommentare und anregungen
starten
gucken wir uns erst mal an was
eigentlich so die medienforschung sagt
zu dem großen thema medienwandel
vertrauen in die nachrichten da gibt es
nämlich immer wieder jedes jahr um
fragen und verändern sich die werte nina
niebergall hat das ganze mal für uns
zusammengefasst schnell live digital
nachrichten werden vielfältiger
unübersichtlicher und das vertrauen in
die nachrichtenberichterstattung aller
medien sinkt
man kann den nachrichten meist vertrauen
sagten 2015 noch 60 prozent 2020 nur
noch 45 prozent
der rest ist unentschieden oder stimmt
nicht zu annika seles professorin für
digitalen journalismus in münchen
forscht unter anderem zu
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien und sagt
das vertrauen geht vor allem an den
politischen rändern verloren
zum einen ist da ein boot dass menschen
die eben an diesem politischen rändern
gerade auf der rechten seite sich
befinden
auch diese vielfalt für die öffentlich
rechtliche medien stehen und die auch
teil ihres auftrags ist möglicherweise
gar nicht zwingend möchten
auf der anderen seite denke ich ist es
aber auch genauso wichtig für öffentlich
rechtliche medien dass alle perspektiven
und auch die an den rändern einbezogen
werden zumindest solange sie sich im
demokratischen rahmen bewegen und die
menschenrechte und so weiter achten für
verlässliche informationen aber greifen
die meisten auf öffentlich-rechtliche
angebote zurück vor allem in unsicheren
zeiten sogar die 18 bis 29 jährigen
informierten sich über das corona virus
vor allem bei den öffentlich rechtlichen
gleich dahinter aber youtube auf platz
drei klassische nachrichtensender n tv
und auf platz vier soziale medien auch
auf youtube und anderen sozialen medien
sind ard und zdf natürlich vertreten
aber das engagement der
öffentlich-rechtlichen grundsätzlich
digital ist sicherlich ausbaufähig also
öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk nicht
nur in deutschland aber auch in
deutschland ist relativ spät daran
gewesen den digitalen wandel zu
gestalten dass sind andere öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunkanstalten
beispielsweise die bbc in großbritannien
oder öle in finnland zweite ich früher
dran gewesen und junge menschen finden
corona nachrichten auf youtube zwar
nicht so seriös und glaubwürdig wie
öffentlich rechtliches fernsehen dafür
aber ausgewogen
das kann man sich natürlich auch mit
diesem grundsätzlichen merkmal dieser
plattform erklären dass dort eben jeder
posten kann jeder seine meinung oder
seine inhalte kundtun kann und damit
natürlich auch sehr viele verschiedene
stimmen dort vorkommen und jeder das
gefühl hat er findet dort eben auch
unterschiedliche dinge oder könnte sich
zumindest mit seiner meinung sofern sie
abweicht entsprechend einbringen
da können auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen ansätzen findet
annika sie diskutieren auch unbequeme
meinungen anhören und zwar auf allen
plattformen also einiges zu tun bei mir
ist bettina schausten stellvertretende
zdf-chefredakteur in und leiterin der
hauptredaktion aktuelles mit ihren wir
heute besprechen was wir besser machen
können anders machen können in den
nachrichten fragen kommentare bitte
gerne unten rein stellen aber bevor ich
auf eure eingehe habe ich nochmal eine
nämlich sie haben gerade gesehen das
vertrauen hat nachgelassen in diese
nachrichten spektrum natürlich sind das
viele verschiedene nachrichten ins zdf
gibt es ziemlich hohe vertrauenswerte
aber unterm strich ist es halt doch
gesunken
hat sie das überrascht nee das ist ja
eigentlich eine entwicklung die wir die
letzten jahre schon sehen und die geht
natürlich einher mit einem
vertrauensverlust im grunde auch für
alle großen institutionen dass das magna
parteien das merken gewerkschaften das
merken die medien
das merken die kirchen da ist schon eine
große bewegung im gange
ich denke aber trotzdem man muss ja
schon sehr ernst nehmen denn wir müssen
uns ja genau darum bemühen vertrauen zu
gewinnen und glaubwürdig zu sein ich
glaube das ist die voraussetzung dafür
dass ist unser kapital
wer wir sind man muss den zusammenhang
nochmal sehen darauf angewiesen dass die
menschen in diesem land dass die
gesellschaft einen öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk will an ein
öffentlich rechtliches fernsehen will
und dafür bereit ist auch geld zu zahlen
und diese bereitschaft ist eben nur da
wenn wir auch überzeugen können wenn wir
wenn das was wir bieten eben auch eine
gewisse allgemeine zustimmung findet
darum müssen wir werben indem wir eben
qualität liefern und zuverlässig sind
bei ihnen landen ja auch viele
beschwerden auf dem tisch die müssen sie
teilweise selbst beantworten wenn es
richtig
um harte beschwerden geht was ist denn
so wenn sie mal versuchen dann fazit zu
ziehen das feedback von zuschauern was
am meisten kritisierten häufigsten
kritisiert wird na ja es ist schon
häufig natürlich das dass sie mein
fehler zu entdecken wie das kann man
aber meistens oder sehr schnell erklären
oft ist es vielleicht auch ein
ein punkt der aufmerksamkeit den ich
richtig da war oder sie denken es fehlt
irgendetwas also es fehlt ein bestimmtes
thema was nicht beleuchtet wird das ist
natürlich auch häufig so und was schon
in den letzten jahren auch vorgehen
zugenommen hat ist der vorwurf oder der
eindruck jedenfalls der zuschauer das
vielleicht nicht alles alle meinungen
zur sprache kommen das ja wir
möglicherweise seiten ausgrenzen
ich fand ganz interessant die die
wissenschaftlerin die da gerade sprach
und eben sagte öffentlich weil ich es
muss sich eben um vielfalt bemühen die
vielfalt wird von kritikern aber oft gar
nicht gewünscht
wir müssen uns um vielfalt bemühen das
finde ich auch eben auch bis an die
ränder aber da gibt es eben auch klare
grenzen und die gehören auch zu unserem
auftrag da wohl jemand meinungen oder
pamphlete loslassen will dass etwas
nicht mehr demokratisch nicht mehr auf
dem boden des grundgesetzes ist da haben
wir auch keine verpflichtungen ihn
einzuladen im gegenteil
dann sollten wir das vielleicht eher
lassen aber ich werde da sollte man die
grenzen nicht zu eng ziehen
man sollte da möglichkeiten finden aber
es muss nicht immer in jeder sendung
sein weil es auch gar nicht geht das ist
tatsächlich wenn ich jetzt mal so in die
kommentare schon mal gucken
der größte kritikpunkt wie sie richtig
schon auch selber festgestellt haben es
kommen also solche sachen wie warum ich
muss man gerade so suchen das war zum
beispiel dass der name wolfgang wodarg
ist gefallen dass der erst bekannt haid
erlangt jetzt in der korona krise als
kritik habe aber frontal 21 einmal zu
wort gekommen und danach ist er relativ
bekannt geworden über youtube und dann
wurde ich gefragt warum wird er nicht
eingeladen in talkshows er hat das hier
war jemand der ja mal gesagt hat corona
ist nicht schlimmer ist eine grippe das
stimmt alles überhaupt gar nicht
ist dass jemand wo sie dann sagen würden
den kann man dann nicht mehr einladen
weil seine meinung einfach nicht mehr
fakten basiert ist oder sollte man das
recht einladen um dann zu gucken was da
dran und mit diesem land noch ins
gespräch zu kommen hier ja die die frage
ist in der tat ist es jetzt einfach eine
meinung ich glaube gerade in der korona
phase war ja am anfang einfach die
unsicherheit sehr großmann mann war auch
mit vielen vermeintlichen experten
konfrontiert die sind dann aber nachher
als solche nicht herausstellten und ich
glaube das zeigt ja dieses beispiel das
am anfang man ihm durchaus auch dieser
stimme durchaus unvoreingenommen
begegnet ist eben auch sichtweisen
zugelassen hat je mehr sich glaube ich
auch redakteure journalisten und das ist
ja unser auftrag dann aber auch damit
befassten wurde ja auch mehr und mehr
klar dass da offenbar eine einzelmeinung
vorherrscht die ein auch nicht wirklich
weiterbringt weil sie eben auch gleich
instrumentalisiert wurde und dann sich
eher in einer art politischen bereich
bewegte und das ist dann am ende auch
die aufgabe von journalisten von
redakteuren die auch talkshows bestücken
zu sagen holen wir uns jetzt eine eine
abseitige meinung er hinein die
zustimmung gefunden hat im netz eia dir
sagen ja es ist nicht unsere aufgabe
dann er uns vielleicht nicht in
talkshows aber in anderen bereichen das
haben sie heute zum beispiel hat das ja
auch gemacht und dann damit der sache
auseinanderzusetzen
also hat der mann recht hat er nicht
recht kann man ihm trauen kann man ihm
nicht trauen wenn man zu dem schluss
kommt da geht es eigentlich nicht um
eine stimme in der sache sondern es geht
darum eine bestimmte sicht auf die dinge
auch vielleicht eine politische sicht
auf die dinge durchzudrücken dann glaube
ich muss auch redaktion und hat auch
eine redaktion die freiheit zu sagen den
laden wir nicht einer man wir müssen uns
natürlich damit auseinandersetzen das
ist schon recht sie haben gerade gesagt
vielfalt wird nicht erwünscht gerade von
den kritikern hier antwortet ihnen
jemand auf youtube die die
wissenschaftlerin in ihrem beitrag hin
zitiert ja aber er sagt vielfalt wird
erwünscht gerade von den kritik ja ich
würde auch sagen vielfalt
zurecht erwünscht und die müssen wir
auch auf liefern was der gedanke den die
dame hatte in ihrem beitrag war ja der
dass gerade die kritiker dann aber
häufig genug sich herausstellt dass ihr
die vielfalt nicht wünschen wenn es
nämlich um abweichende meinung kann
jeder der das ist meine erfahrung viele
die dann so vehement einfordern dass
ihre meinung dort nicht zum tragen kommt
und dass ein bisschen verschleiern
hinter dem vorwurf hier zeigt nicht alle
meinungen ihr braucht mehr vielfalt
stellt sich dann leicht heraus dass
eigentlich vor allem eine meinung
nämlich die eigene gehört werden will
und das war glaube ich in diesem
motorrad sicher nachvollziehbar oder
wenn ich jetzt das gefühl habe ich weiß
ich nicht ich bin halt zum beispiel
gegen abtreibung nur das ist ja was soll
ich auch streitbar weil man jetzt wie
man doch erst begründet würde ich jetzt
nicht ausführen aber zum hat eine
meinung die jetzt nicht dem mainstream
entspricht und hat dann das gefühl da
ist sind zu wenig fürsprecher in den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien so was für
euch ja immer wieder auch aus dem
konservativ rechts konservativen
spektrum dass sie sagen ihr nehmt uns
nicht ernst sobald ihr was sagen wird
dass runter gemacht ich habe hier auch
einen kommentar gerade schon gelesen ich
such mal kurz der quasi genau in die
richtung gehen wenn die genau hier peter
thomann potato man wahrscheinlich sagt
vertraut uns kein meter das training ist
bis in die nachrichtenformate
vorgedrungen ft dützen wo spd und grüne
kritisieren das einzige was er noch
liefert ist kritische berichterstattung
gegen rechts dies natürlich braucht
während der andere extreme ausblendet
das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen das
was da gemeint ist nur dass vielfalt in
dem sinne empfunden nichts da ist ja
also es führt aber in die richtung
ich glaube ich wüsste nicht wann in
unserer nachrichtensendungen ich glaube
auch nicht bei heute plus dieses frame
stattgefunden hat was er als fremming
bezeichnet also ist es so dass das die
nachrichtensendungen jetzt bei uns über
die kann ich ja nur sprechen tatsächlich
davon reden dass die afg jetzt wenn dann
muss das in einem zusammenhang begründet
sein und es muss gezeigt werden und
diskutiert werden ist das so ist das
eine einschätzung die an
da haben also das kann ich so nicht
stehen lassen und auch nicht ganz
nachvollziehen aber es geht da natürlich
um genau diesen vorwurf dass sozusagen
man auf einer seite blind sei in diesem
sender und das hat ein bisschen ja eine
geschichte ich bin ich glaube das ist
das ist jetzt natürlich seit der
diskussion nach der flüchtlingskrise das
aufkommen von biggi da die gründung der
afd
das ist da natürlich in den letzten
jahren ja eine sehr angeheizte
politische debatte gegeben hat in der
sich allerdings dann auch herausgestellt
hatte dass leider viele fdp-vertreter
tatsächlich offenbar nicht auf dem boden
des grundgesetzes stehen das haben wir
nun ich glaube auch sehr sauber und
ordentlich berichtet und das übrigens
ohne berührungsängste
ich war ja bis zum letzten jahr viele
jahre in berlin und habe da das
hauptstadtbüro geleitet und wir haben
uns da ist man nah dran an der politik
und wir haben uns da schon sehr mit
auseinandergesetzt und hatten da haben
da auch nach wie vor teile kollegen die
sich intensiv mit der afg
auseinandersetzen und überhaupt keine
berührungsängste haben die auch mit den
diskussionen führen reden um dann fair
zu berichten
aber was ein problem ist oder womit ich
ein problem habe ist mit dem vorwurf zu
sagen das findet bei euch alles nicht
statt
das glaube ich stimmt nicht ich glaube
also ich verstehe das meistens so dass
die zuschauer teilweise wenn sie dieser
meinung sind eigentlich keine einordnung
wollen sondern sie wollen ihr die das
stehen gelassen wird
wenn die afg sagt wir reden hier kommen
messer mädchen das ist ja so ein zitat
von alois seidl gewesen in der
bundestags runde messer mädchen und die
messer männer war das und
kopftuchmädchen so besser männer macht
schon genau dass man ganz einfach stehen
lässt als legitime meinung unter nicht
einordnet dass das zum beispiel ein
realistischer kommentar ist in welchen
formaten würden sie das denn sehen ist
das auch was wurden ich sag mal eine
nachrichtensendung die einfach den tag
ab bildet das auch stehen lässt und das
heute journal als magazin was ich dann
ja auch mal eine eine einordnung zumutet
oder zutraut oder auch gewünscht
dass man das unterschiedlich behandelt
also ich glaube diese einordnung hat so
vielfach gegeben also das war natürlich
habe ich meine das gefühl dass sie
wollen aber diese kritiker wollen diese
einordnung gar nicht haben sie nun quasi
sie für sich selber bilden und nicht vom
fernsehen gesagt bekommen wie sie das
tut gut dabei das ist dann vielleicht an
einen anspruch also letzter punkt ja
richtig ich möchte auch hier nicht
täglich belehren und ich möchte nicht
ich bin auch ziemlich auch gar nicht als
instanz dass ich dem zuschauer oder wir
dem zuschauer sagen wissen so musst du
denken und so darfst du nicht denken das
ist nicht unsere aufgabe und das ist das
ist nicht unsere rolle aber die
einordnung die die kommt und wenn jemand
die nicht will dann hat er ein problem
im zdf denn wir werden etwas immer
einordnen das tun wir aber mit einem
grünen o ton und mit einem tollen der
bundeskanzlerin auch so also eingeordnet
warum jemand was in welcher situation
sagt geschieht immer das ist auch unsere
aufgabe zu untersuchen warum wird das so
gemacht und bei dem bau weiter beispiel
war es natürlich so dass das eine die
schärfste provokation war die auch viel
mehr sollte als es nur zu sagen dass
sollte was auslösen
von alison ist natürlich das war der
sinn dahinter und das hat natürlich auch
was ausgelöst und wissen sie alles
weitere ist insofern muss ich dem user
darauf dann auch hinweisen sie war
vielfach oder mehrfach auch im zdf
sendung und in einer erinnere ich mich
vor vor allem wahltermin hat sie
ebenfalls auch nur den eklat gesucht und
hat das studio verlassen hat unter
vorwürfen die noch gemurmelt wurden das
studio verlassen weil dahinter natürlich
auch ein gewisses muster steht das
kennen wir bei der ard gerne in eine art
opfer rolle zu schlüpfen zu sagen da
seht her die öffentlich rechtlichen
haben mich hier wieder gelöscht also
konnte ich nur noch gehen und das sind
muster die kann man nicht einfach so
stehen lassen
man sieht aber wir haben sie eingeladen
das hat stattgefunden sie hatte alle
möglichkeiten mit zu diskutieren
aber darum ging es ihr offenbar nicht
sondern um den eklat
die einordnung die sehe ich auch so dass
das unser job als journalist oder
journalistinnen
hier kommt jetzt aber zum beispiel das
passt ganz gut antonio munoz per twitter
dm hat geschrieben er kann
vorausgeschickt sagen dass er
grundsätzlich befürworte das öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunks ist hier seht ihr
gerade mein dokument wo die kollegen das
rein gruppiert haben damit ich nicht
alles gleichzeitig angucken muss so und
er schreibt in den letzten jahren wird
jedoch zunehmend deutlich dass sich
viele journalisten und journalistinnen
immer weniger als berichterstatter
verstehen sondern als multi platin
multiplikatoren der guten sache
auftreten möchten
worunter offenbar meist grüne position
verstanden werden also lese ich daraus
ja ein ort nun ja aber es kommt zu oft
aus einer vermeintlich grünen oder
linken ecke
[Musik]
also was ist da dran
auch das hat ja jetzt schon so ein
bisschen eine geschichte dieser dieser
vorwurf hängt auch mit dem worüber wir
davor gesprochen haben durchaus zusammen
der wird ja auch der wird ja auch immer
wieder multipliziert und fortgesetzt und
man interessierter seite immer wieder
dafür gibt's ja auch ausdrücke und
beschimpfungen
aber ich will diese den kern solcher
vorwürfe durchaus ernst nehmen weil weil
ich schon als meine aufgabe sehe dass
mich damit auseinander zu setzen und es
gab glaube ich schon gewisse zeiten
konnten zuschauer konnten user den
eindruck gewinnen
journalistisch interessierte den
eindruck gewinnen dass möglicherweise
die shanghai ja sozusagen in einer
richtung unterwegs
das seien nicht nicht wirklich genug pro
und contra auseinandersetzung da war
dass das will ich durchaus zugestehen
dass auch aus der berliner warte im
übrigen dass das da manchmal auch in
früheren jahren fehler gemacht worden
sind und auch bei öffentlich-rechtlichen
vielleicht fehler gemacht worden sind
die allerdings jetzt eigentlich nicht
darin lagen dass man sich jetzt so zum
anwalt der guten sache machen wollte
unter einem bestimmten politischen
vorzeichen
sondern ich glaube dass wir eines nicht
richtig konnten dass wir nicht früh
genug wahrgenommen haben dass wir schon
seit langem nicht mehr nur in eine
richtung senden also dass wir sender
sind das war ja nun die alte funktion
des fernsehens sondern dass es mit dem
netz
da schließt sich jetzt der krise am
anfang den rückkanal gibt also das was
wir hier jetzt heute abend machen
das ist ja der große vorzug der ganzen
digitalisierung der letzten jahrzehnte
so ist aber fernsehen zum beispiel und
auch so traditions- fernsehen wie die
öffentlich rechtlichen nicht gestartet
sondern die waren natürlich in einer in
einer situation wir senden und liebe
fernseh zur genauen liebes volk
empfangen und seid fröhlich wird und das
ging natürlich in zeiten wo dann eine
samstagabend schon straßenfeger war ging
das alles noch ganz gut aber das hat
sich geändert und ich glaube dass wir da
uns auch durchaus selbstkritisch mit
befasst haben auch schon und müssen dass
wir so sagen da nicht früh genug darauf
geachtet haben und vielleicht auch
anfänglich auf den zu hohen ross also
ich gebe es aber noch mal positives
feedback hier das ist ja auch schöne
bernies schreibt auf facebook wenig an
das verschnarchte zdf der 80 hat enke
seid ihr auf dem besten weg wieder mehr
zuschauer einzufahren und die heute show
erst also da gibt es durchaus durch auch
aus auch fans marco schreibt ich finde
es einfach schade man sieht wie der
blick auf die öffentlich-rechtlichen
heute ist und sich da von seiten derer
gefühlt keine gedanken gemacht werden da
weiß ich nicht ganz marco wenn du meinst
ob die kritiker mainz oder ob du das
meinst eine sache finde ich ganz
interessant von wege place kita auch auf
youtube neutralität das ist ja ein sehr
großer anspruch von journalismus auch
das öffentlich rechtlichen erreicht man
meiner meinung nach durch breite und
tiefe der berichterstattung
hier gibt es eklatante nachholbedarf
hier möchte ich noch mal danke sagen
dass es auch eine konstruktive gedanke
ist da hätte ich gern ganz gerne noch
mehr fahren also tatsächlich nicht nur
was euch stört sondern sagt muss doch
mal was hier anders machen möchte aber
hier quasi die beschwerde es gibt
nachholbedarf ich nehme das mal
konstruktiv auf und sagt wir brauchen
mehr tiefe in der berichterstattung
da bin ich jetzt sehr dabei ich weiß
nicht wie der name war begeistert place
geht und das ist auch sehr sympathisch
ja also dem würde ich total recht geben
weil das ist das wodurch wir nur
überzeugen können durch gute inhalte und
geprüfte inhalte dass es ja auch unser
versprechen und mehr tiefe und die
möglichkeiten dazu hat aber eben auch
öffentlich rechtlich ist das ist auch
ein teil wofür wofür die leute bezahlen
das können sie dann auch zu recht
erwarten
aber das schöne ist dass ich an dem
punkt habe ich jetzt fühle ich mich gar
nicht in der defensive sondern da kann
ich glaube ich wirklich sagen wenn man
mal sender medien vergleicht da stehen
wir ganz gut da und eben auch jetzt im
netz mehr und mehr auch wenn man da noch
nicht so weit sind finde ich wie wir
vielleicht sein müssten oder sein
könnten
aber ich glaube so was grafik videos
angeht was erkläre räume angeht was auch
gerade im zdf bestimmte bereiche angeht
die wissenschaft wie geschichte
ich finde da haben wir schon ziemlich
viel zu bieten und das ganz
selbstbewusst vertreten
hier geht es manchmal eine sache jetzt
war sie zu dieser meinung und
verschiedene anordnungen die finde ich
auch ganz interessant war das waren
worte das ist den letzten jahren häufig
gefallen nämlich haltung einer yusuf
schreibt hier wann wird haltung
journalismus beendet also das ist ja
auch ein vorwurf erhaltung journalismus
steckt schon wieder dieses pädagogische
von oben herab so habt ihr das zu sehen
oder zu denken was die leute haben die
frage was moral ist und was das haltung
also ja also ich habe mit beiden
begriffen ein bisschen ein problem also
natürlich gibt es ein neutralitätsgebot
was aber eben heißt das zdf plakatiert
jetzt nicht für eine partei und
staatsferne gehört dazu
also neutralitätsgebot geht aber am ende
sind wir nicht neutral in dem sinne dass
wir sagen wir geben ihm jeden plattform
die er nutzen kann und macht damit was
ihr wollt das ist eben nicht unsere
aufgabe
und von daher sind wir unparteiisch
aber auch jetzt nicht vollkommen neutral
jedenfalls nicht an dem punkt wo es um
demokratie werte grundgesetz geht und so
und die haltung ich glaube darüber sind
inzwischen auch staunen doktorarbeiten
glaube ich auch da ist die frage ist es
tatsächlich so gibt es nur haltungs
journalisten also gerade in den
nachrichten würde ich mal sagen hier und
da weißt du ja eine sehr gute haltung
definiert glaub ich ja das wieder was
anderes als wenn es darum geht dass das
auch journalisten aktivisten werden dann
würde ich zustimmen dann sage ich dass
das ist mein weg nicht das mag sein dass
das grenzfälle gibt aber wer sozusagen
sein journalistisches ethos ernst nimmt
der der kümmert sich eben um die dinge
und um die verklärung der dinge und
sorgt dafür dass die leute am ende sich
die meinung bilden aber wann fängt das
an mit dem aktivismus wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel merkt eine firma macht sachen
die wir nicht gut finden die schwierig
sind für die umwelt zum beispiel und man
fängt wirklich andere hat zu
recherchieren auch immer wieder
berichtet zu machen dann können ja von
der firma der vorwurf kommen dass des
aktivismus krise des journalismus und
das ist investigativer journalismus und
im zweifel auch harter journalismus und
der muss sein denn der guckt jedem auf
die finger dass dabei ist wichtig man
darf halt nicht nur in eine richtung
immer gucken sondern das muss man in
alle richtungen machen und auch da finde
ich haben wir ja mit frontal21 eine
tolle adresse im zdf zu zu bieten
also das ist das ist durchaus
journalismus nein man aktivistisch wird
man dann wenn man so sagen aus der rolle
des journalisten heraustritt und sich
eben bewusst und klar für eine für eine
position einsetzt auch mit seinem namen
und seiner person es gibt dafür fälle
die finde ich auch anerkennenswert und
gut sind aber wenn man es mal vom
grundsatz her betrachtet dann ist die
aufgabe des journalisten auch unsere
aufgaben eben eine andere und da steht
nicht auf der stirn geschrieben was
jetzt die eigene meinung ist so ich
schaue noch mal was es hier noch so gibt
die haben jetzt viel über genau dieses
thema neutralität meinung hat
gesprochen das scheint tatsächlich die
meisten leute zu bewegen
ich habe manchmal so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass es da auch an der
tatsächlichen an dem wissen fehlt welche
art von journalismus hätten was ist wie
würden sie das unterscheiden also denn
es gibt ja durchaus ein unterschied
zwischen im nachrichtenformat wie der
heute 19 uhr und eine nachrichtenmagazin
wir denn heute journal wenn sie die mal
auseinander dividieren würden was machen
die kollegen jeweils unterschiedlich
also die dass das nachricht die
nachrichtensendung muss natürlich ganz
klar sein einst eine einsatz nach dem
anderen ist muss gut verständlich sein
es muss die fakten wiedergeben es muss
erklären es sollte am ende etwas
hängenbleiben und zwar wirklich einfach
von der von der nachricht an sich das
magazin hat dann schon die aufgabe einen
schritt weiter zu gehen und ein stärker
nach dem warum zu fragen stärker noch
mal nach zusammenhängen zu forschen und
und und am ende vielleicht eben auch
noch stärker pro und contra gegen dann
dazu dass das ist natürlich oft in
interviews der fall da wird moderatorin
zb auch oft dann aus dass so ausgelegt
dass sie auf einer politischen seite
stünden dabei ist nun das klassische
interview im grunde so gestrickt dass
man als moderator eine gegenposition
einnimmt
das ist muss nicht unbedingt die
persönliche eigene sein aber man muss
das gegenüber natürlich mit den
schwierigen fragen konfrontieren und
nicht nach dem munde reden also von
daher das sind unterschiede in magazinen
werden interviews geführt auch kritische
interviews geführt in
nachrichtensendungen eben nicht aber ich
will an der stelle jetzt nochmal noch
einmal ein haken was was auch so seien
die glaubwürdigkeit und der eindruck von
verlässlichkeit angeht weil vorher ja
auch diesen beitrag gesehen haben was
mich total hoffnungsfroh stimmt ist
schon dass wir jetzt eben während der
korona monate gesehen haben dass das
auch jüngere zuschauer und zwar sehr
viele tatsächlich auch zutrauen offenbar
zu uns gefunden haben jetzt muss man
sich nichts vormachen die situation war
und alle waren zu hause
und alle hat ein wahnsinniges
informationsbedürfnis aber wir haben
jedenfalls während dieser phase eine
hohe akzeptanz gab 20 prozent mehr
zuschauer davon auch viele jüngere
jüngere heißt ja immer unter 50 oder
unter 49 und das find ich schon stimmt
mich echt hoffnungsfroh weil ich doch
auch denke viele studien haben uns immer
schon gesagt vergesst die jungen für die
seite überhaupt kein interesse mehr aber
offenbar sind wir dann doch noch eine
jedenfalls so dass wir da noch 56
millionen zuschauer einsammeln um 19 uhr
abends und das finde ich finde ich
klasse so ich habe jetzt mal tatsächlich
ein bisschen gesammelt ich habe ein paar
anregungen bekommen also einer therapie
schreibt vorschlag zur verbesserung
längere nachrichten andere länder haben
30 bis 60 minuten nachrichten pro tag in
15 minuten das ist ungefähr länge der
heute der 19 uhr heute bis 20 minuten
lang kann man natürlich nicht zu viel
reinpacken wie von der mehrheit
gewünscht wäre dass ich meine die street
journal ist schon 30 minuten lang
das stimmt aber so bbc und so was die
machen auch 60 minuten am tag wäre das
eine maßnahme dass man tatsächlich dann
noch mehr machen kann
also ich bin die nachrichtenchefin
jahren aber es ist natürlich so ich
finde sie sind schon ganz gut
aufgestellt eben mit 20 21 minuten heute
sendung im fernsehen jetzt im journal
mir aber ganz starken über in einem jahr
nur noch es stimmt das soll ja auch den
kompakten überblick liefern die leute
sind ja noch in einer lebenssituation wo
sie was weiß ich mit den kindern noch
unterwegs sind oder zu abend essen das
soll auch die möglichst kompakten
überblick den sich die leute natürlich
auch oft genug heute ja woanders holen
den schnellen überblick eben eben im
netz diese 60 minuten format es gibt ja
auch dieses berühmte sechste minute sind
dann aber eigentlich schon gar nicht
mehr klassische nachrichtenformate
sondern auch wieder eher magazin format
und wenn man da mal guckt dem zdf dann
würde ich dazu eigentlich auch so
angebote wie frontal21 zählen dazu würde
ich wie so zählen dafür
dazu würde ich das auslandsjournal also
wenn heute journal läuft und danach dann
außerdem journal dann dann hat man schon
eine gute stunde und zwar erstklassige
berichterstattungen also das kann ich
nur empfehlen eine andere anregung von
rübe ratlos ihr habt wirklich richtigen
namen heute ein internet foren wo man
themen eingeben kann über die dann
recherchiert und berichtet wird als
anregung nicht schlecht so dass man
hingeht und sagt ich möchte mir über xy
wissen das ist das ist nicht schlecht
wobei eigentlich geschieht es so ein
bisschen ja schon ne also wir haben ja
jetzt bei der zdf- heute- mir nochmal
ein relaunch seit märz gehabt und da
haben wir auch noch mal sehr viel kraft
in faktencheck gelegt und häufig kommen
ja die themen die anregung aus dem netz
na also jedenfalls haben die kolleginnen
und kollegen das ja im blick und
recherchieren dann themen themen
hinterher und also da hatten jetzt eine
ganz tolle geschichte in kooperation von
zdf heute mit frontal21 wirklich
investigativ da ging es um um impfen um
ärzte die zusagen bescheinigung
ausstellen und die impfung hat nicht
stattgefunden
also das ist so ein beispiel da da kam
im grunde da sind ja auch drauf gestoßen
aus dem netz und aber so finde ich
trotzdem einen interessanten gedanken
haben könnte und dann vielleicht sachen
hoch und runter wählen
ein wunsch war mehr quellen zeigen das
zdf wird die quelle nicht zeigen ist im
fernsehen ein bisschen schwierig online
geht das natürlich und dann habe ich bei
mir auf meinem privaten instagram kanal
mal meine follower gefragt was sie sich
wünschen würden
und da kam ganz häufig nicht mehr keine
reißerische überschriften zum beispiel
weniger klick dating aber was ich noch
besser fand häufig der wunsch positive
berichterstattung also konstruktive
sachen zu zeigen lösungen zu zeigen
nicht immer das hatte ich heute morgen
wieder ich höre die nachrichten im
deutschlandfunk und denken daher um
gottes willen die welt geht den bach
runter weil da krise dort hier sind dort
krieg und sogar erst einmal abends bei
wir bemühen ich da schon immer oder
haben uns mal bemüht auch mal was
positives zu zeigen aber mehr
konstruktive lösungen statt immer nur
das problem zu zeigen ist das ein ansatz
ja ist ein super ansatz und der wird ja
auch schon praktiziert
übrigen auch im zdf wir haben ja plan b
eine sendung die sich wirklich genug mit
mit konstruktiven ansätzen beschäftigt
ich finds auch für nachrichtensendungen
interessant was ist aber nicht sein darf
ist dass man die welt nur noch rosig
sieht das ist die kehrseite dann wird
alles ins positive gelenkt und man hat
verliert den blick für die
ernsthaftigkeit und die den denn das
drängende problem also da muss man ein
bisschen aufpassen ob es für die
nachrichten auch was ist aber es gibt so
ansätze mitfährt das nicht auch gegangen
hat das ganze nicht auch was gutes
können wir das nicht auch positiv sehen
das sind so ansatz fragen mit denen man
tatsächlich auch damit man nicht immer
nur vor dem problem steht und sagt ich
kann sowieso nichts machen so jetzt
kommen wir mal zu dem wie wir
weitermachen werden denn das zdf sie
haben es gerade schon gesagt ist im
wandel wir haben die zdf- heute- app
komplett renoviert ich hoffe ihr habt
sie alle geladen
dann kriegt ja auch immer ein putsch
wenn wir live gehen
wir werden weiter arbeiten mit
verschiedenen formaten es gab aber auch
den vorwurf konnte gerade gehört von
anja annika der medienwissenschaftlerin
das zdf oder generell die öffentlich
rechtlichen haben zu spät auf
digitalisierung reagiert woran hat das
gelegen was würden sie sagen ja ich
glaube wir haben vielleicht zu spät
kamen gründe zusammen ich glaube wir
waren in der tat ein bisschen spät wir
haben schon stark lange aufs fernsehen
gesetzt und auch einfach darauf dass das
ist nach wie vor die das leitmedium ins
gruppen- und deshalb stimmten also auch
viele dieser ganzen studien die wir da
schon sehr früh gehört haben in
spätestens zwei drei jahren sind die
leute alle umgestiegen stimmten dann gar
nicht so also aber es ist natürlich dann
trotz eines beitrags und trotzdem trotz
der finanzierung auch durch die
gesellschaft und die öffentlichkeit
nicht ganz leicht dass das eine mit
voller kraft zu tun und ein zweites
standbein nebenbei auch noch mal wieso
bauen und das ist nicht gelungen denn
wir haben auch jahre und das ist ja auch
im sinne der öffentlichkeit jahre in
denen wir auch sparen mussten in dem wir
uns kleiner gesetzt haben in denen wir
auch gerade junge
auch freie mitarbeiter wieder keine
chance geben konnten im zdf das waren
gleichzeitig die jahre
dort werden drei hätte einbauen müssen
und so und jetzt kann man natürlich auch
sagen und da da bin ich auch dabei dass
man sagt gut dann könnt ihr nicht alles
in gleiche machen im gleichen maße
machen sondern wir müssen halt mit euren
kräften auch besser haushalten und sehen
wer was macht wir haben jetzt aber noch
mal tatsächlich auch eine initiative
entworfen und helm sind bei zdf heute
glaube ich jetzt noch mal ein stück
vorangekommen ist jedenfalls mein
eindruck und ich würde hoffen dass der
eine oder andere auch so sieht also ich
glaube rundum datenjournalismus
faktencheck die ganze grafik die
erläuterung die erklärt tiefe die vorhin
mal angesprochen wurde
da haben wir jetzt fortschritte gemacht
und jetzt ist nur noch die kunst dass
man sozusagen das beste was wir ja auch
im fernsehen machen an content und an
guten erklärungen und interessanten
themen
das eben auch gut ins netz zu zu
transformieren
es reicht ja nicht nur die sendungen
eben live zu stellen das wissen wir auch
sondern wir müssen es ja auch so
aufarbeiten dass die user da ist auch
nutzen so jetzt gibt es tatsächlich hier
auch lob german social search noch mal
danke an euch dass ihr hier fragen
aufnimmt das solltet ihr öfter tun
tim heidenreich meint gerne solche
formate interaktive nachrichten mit
jemanden der sich mit fragen der
zuschauer beschäftigt gerne im stream
anschließend noch eine diskussion so ja
damit rennt ihr ein grund eröffnet uhren
bei uns ein
denn wenn ihr es nicht mitbekommen habe
die letzte heute plus sendung im
fernsehen läuft morgen abend aber das
heißt nicht dass wir aufhören sondern
wir machen weiter was steckt hinter
dieser entscheidung vorher wird das da
schließt sich jetzt wirklich an denn
heute plus war ja nun wirklich auch ein
format und eine redaktion die man ja
hier auch noch zum teil sieht sind nicht
alle daten
eine redaktion die da in den letzten
fünf jahren super arbeit gemacht hat und
wirklich viel erfahrungen gesammelt hat
was crossmedialität angeht was themen
aus dem netz aufnehmen geht was
erklärung angeht grafik videos eure
erklärvideos das hat ja jetzt schon
früchte getragen das ist ja jetzt schon
in anderen sendungen 1 gesichert aber
man kann auch dieser und eurer kleinen
überschaubaren redaktion nicht die ganze
aufgabe zwang alleine geben und deshalb
haben wir eben gesagt dass es jetzt ein
guter moment auch seit wir diese
verstärkte zdf heute das angebot haben
dass wir eben sagen wir wir tragen jetzt
die fackel mal weiter und zwar in
mehrere richtungen gleich also wir
wollen einmal kollegen auch eure
erfahrung uns heute journal tragen die
werden sich dann auch künftig um eine
späte sendung kümmern und ein anderer
teil wird sich stärker genau und das
kümmern was jetzt auch gerade an klang
der mich live streams zu machen auch das
gespräch mit den usern zu suchen und zu
intensivieren und auch ein stück für
transparenz zu sorgen und das finde ich
ist eine tolle entwicklung es wandelt
sich alles ist wandelt sich schnell und
alles muss weitergehen und ich glaube
dass dies in zukunft schritt ist das
werden wir weiter verfolgen und ich
hoffe ihr seid dabei ich würde mich
freuen und ich darf schon noch mal danke
sagen für fünf jahre heute schon sehr
gerne als war deutlich habt ihr toll
gemacht und auch diesen jungen mann wird
man weiterhin sehen in den livestreams
das haben wir uns fest vorgenommen
ich sage danke frau chancen dass sie
heute haben sich zeit genommen haben ich
sage euch danke für lob und kritik und
eure anregungen die es dann ja doch gab
ich fand es wichtig dass wir darüber
reden was wir alles anders machen können
dass wir uns auch erklären weil
tatsächlich die medien funktionieren
wissen man für medienmacher auch
manchmal nicht so richtig das ist auch
nicht so einfach zu durchblicken
es ist ein laden oder ein system das
sehr schnell und sehr agil ist und dann
muss man manchmal anhalten und
sagenstoff was machen wir eigentlich
gerade genau das tun wir jetzt hier das
wenn wir auch weiter tun in diesem sinne
an dieser stelle dass der letzten live
stream gewesen in diesem studio in
diesem set wir basteln was neues ihr
könnt gespannt sein und das geht nach
einer sommerpause dann weiter wie ich
sag jetzt aber erstmal für hier
viel spaß noch für heute plus und wenn
euch der leistung gefallen habe dann
guck doch mal hier da haben wir auch
noch ein und über die frage warum so
viele menschen an die große corona
verschwörung glauben oder hier ein
livestream mit dem biologen martin
stürner über die korona app und was er
sich gewünscht hätte und außerdem könnte
hierfür über den kanal abonnieren und
leichter lassen